hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch from our
friends arts peer entertainment they're
Captain Marvel trailer spoof yay they
are two hard-working individuals who are
hilarious ass people listen guys before
we go into that I wanted to give a shout
out to our friends over at 4dx as you
can see with the footage playing over
right now they are holding for a Captain
Marvel screen X there's not some paid
sponsorship deal I'm hoping that by
shouting them out they'll hook us up
with a screening at least to go watch us
in screen X but as you can see if you're
looking at the seats if you're looking
at the screen it is all around you man
it is all around you there's no
experience like this out there other
than screen X 4 DX friends please Sara
I'm talking to you hook this up with a
screen X screen because that looks
insane to experience a Marvel movie all
around you that would be awesome it
looks like it's like this for most of
the movie if there's ever this old
trailer like that I think it's that way
for the whole man that'd be insane
this isn't Kung Fu Panda at Universal
Studios where it's a surprise or
something yeah it's a hundred percent
man's insanely immersive right there so
yeah guys cool
[Laughter]
haengju
pensioner
[Music]
I was already
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
what's said is you shoot fury it's a
scroll cut no you're gonna punch it I'm
not punching this cat Kara
well we're not going anywhere until you
do that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
that mobile that might be my favorite
one for very specific reasons
let's hear I can't right now because of
the garbage just there transformers
fighting outside I see some obvious like
hilarious ones were I love that she was
really just beating up an old lady it
was dead-set story this lady had this
issue with old ladies and then they just
kept going and just Nair it all down to
just schools hates girls an elderly
woman well yeah that start like this is
a really like visual gag heavy one and
that they all are but I started to pick
up she's got a bunch of little old
ladies stenciled on her fighter jet as
if she's like killed the reason this is
my favorite one is because they made a
character out of Capitol here
whereas the other ones are kind of more
of just jack-of-all-trades you know you
never know what they're gonna say you
never know what jokes are gonna make
with this one with Captain Marvel they
gave her a more defined personality in
this tune sandwich trailer then any of
the trailers combined from marble in the
south she's egotistical mean [ __ ]
it's like a spunky 90s girl yeah like
she's got that kind of cynical sense of
humor and stuff like that she's always
sass and often so yeah it's got this
like sarcasm about her too and a bossy
controlling attitude yeah I was like
watching this going I'm kind of half
hope and Captain Marvel behaves this way
in the movie I know because it's such a
distinct take and it's like because of
all this argument about like hope you
don't really know his sense for her
character I feel like that was the
perfect thing for them to capitalize on
if yeah but eliza ahahaha Marvel I love
that they went with that angle because I
mean regardless of what the movie is
this somehow made me more excited for it
even though I'm sure that she's probably
not gonna be like this exactly she sees
like she has a bit of an attitude in the
movie but but not yeah I love I just
loved the character portrayal they had
of her and also this younger Nick Fury
portrayal as well oh yeah you know that
ending [ __ ] is heavy
though the Caddy starts to cry he just
doesn't want to hit it and she's like
just negative on it just do it just push
the cap here I would watch a full-length
version of this portrayal of captain
Marlowe this is one tune sandwich we'd
have seen of them where I'm like I want
to see a full-length feature film of
just this person right here she sort of
feels like you're like a like an abusive
older brother who's strung out because
they also have that recurring thing like
she's snorting up anchor whatever so
she's always like a little strung out or
something or at least that's the vibe I
catch is like a bully know-it-all
superhero who occasionally mistakes
planes for summer is everything about
this man business is probably my
favorite one because you have given me a
distinct character oh yeah it said you
had the most room to make it your own
and boy did you and I love it seriously
congratulation before we wrap this video
up though we'd like to give a page in
the day shout-out to a man named bro and
Maxon broen he is from Australia John do
your Australian accent brawn makes them
from Australia and you know where these
arts were entertainment guys are from
there from Australia and so is Ben
Mendelsohn who's playing what's his name
it's scroll roll guy oh man this girl
man she'll do Rowan and I ah we've had
some pretty long exchanges back to
fourth we haven't talked in a little bit
and I feel like that's your fault I
haven't checked the messages sometimes
on patreon the messages don't go through
which is really upsetting there have
been times where he has sent me long-ass
messages and then I've sent him a very
long message back and I go to check it a
few days later my message did not go
through so I have to repeat the whole
thing again but it's worth it for you
buddy
because I love you keep up the weight
loss keep up the meditation keep on
colon cleansing yourself I do a colon
cleanse at least eight days a week so
keep cleansing that colon man you don't
want n to play John Wayne don't ever
change your name because you haven't the
most badass name I've ever heard
what's broen mean it means breast it
means breast odd dude a plus man I mean
unless you're a butts guy or something
like that and then it's kind of ironic
no I got my girlfriend to say let's see
them bro ins
let's see them bro is Dan went to
my Megson and your bro yeah what does
magazine mean this is such a like bro
and magazine sounds like a Action Hero
pearl ooh
alright it's not bad breasts pearl is
that like milk I don't know subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification about and please subscribe
to our dear insane man these guys are
awesome congrats again on this video
guys it's awesome thank you